jaime quiere conocer el volumen de su
anillo de oro en pulgadas cúbicas
consigue un vaso rectangular con base de
2 pulgadas por 3 pulgadas aquí están dos
pulgadas por tres pulgadas y llena el
vaso a cuatro pulgadas de altura cuatro
pulgadas de altura esto de acá jaime
mete el anillo en el vaso mide la nueva
altura y obtiene que es de 4.25 pulgadas
aquí está la nueva situación cuál es el
volumen del anillo de jaime en pulgadas
cúbicas bueno pues qué sucede cuando se
mete el anillo aquí en el vaso
el anillo desplaza la misma cantidad de
agua que el anillo tiene como volumen
entonces para encontrar cuál es el
volumen del anillo lo que tenemos que
hacer es ver cuál es la diferencia de
volúmenes en estos dos casos y realmente
ver la diferencia de volúmenes es
prácticamente algo que tiene que ver con
las alturas nada más porque la base es
la misma verdad aquí tenemos una base
rectangular de 3 pulgadas x 2 pulgadas
que es exactamente la misma de acá 3
pulgadas por 2 pulgadas
entonces realmente la diferencia está
hecha por la altura y en este caso
tenemos punto 25 pulgadas más es decir
tenemos un cachito adicional por aquí un
cachito adicional que mide 0.25 pulgadas
pulgadas entonces el nuevo volumen o más
bien la diferencia de volúmenes es justo
esta parte que voy a sombrear es justo
justo este prisma rectangular que estoy
sombreando ahí está la base que está en
la parte de enfrente la parte del lado y
esta parte de aquí arriba donde este
prisma tiene tres pulgadas de este lado
322 pulgadas de este lado de acá más
bien dos pulgadas ahí no se ve muy bien
porque está muy oscuro
voy a pasar por para acá dos pulgadas y
de altura tiene 60 punto 25 pulgadas
bueno y cuánto es ese volumen pues para
encontrar el volumen de un prisma
rectangular hay que multiplicar sus
dimensiones sería 3 por 2
por 0.25 3 por 12 6
queda 6 x 0.25 y esto lo podríamos hacer
con una calculadora o también
mentalmente 4.25 es 1 y faltan 2 x punto
25 o sea punto 5 de esta forma nos queda
uno más punto 5 o sea 1.5 y las unidades
son pulgadas pulgadas
cúbicas
picas cúbicas entonces el volumen del
anillo de jaime es de 1.25 pulgadas
cúbicas lo cual es un anillo muy grande
alomejor jaime tiene dedos muy grandes o
no sé a lo mejor simplemente le gusta
gastar mucho en oro